[Musique]
bonjour on est où là colimaçon oui voilà
voilà cela fait bien coupé ma première
réalisation m'appelle jasmin imposé
alors mon entreprise s'appelle mines
alicia donc c'est une entreprise que
j'ai créée suite à la naissance de ma
fille je fais des créations textiles
pour les enfants les bébés
[Musique]
oui on a fait du bon jour la td alice
est je viens montrer ton atelier de
travail sur saint denis et pour faire la
route par rapport à la saline-les-hauts
saint denis c'était un peu long
du coup je me suis arrêté de travailler
et c'est moi qui avais dit j'aimerais
bien avoir une machine à coudre pour mon
anniversaire
pour pouvoir faire des bavoirs pour la
petite
au début c'est un peu moqué de moi et
ayew ça va servir une semaine que vale
ont trouvé ça en ballon sous sol et puis
finalement non alors ça c'est deux
créations personnalisées
non je dessinais le patron et puis j'ai
créé deux doudou début c'était pour ma
fille et puis après j'ai amélioré pour
pouvoir les vendre et c'est toujours
bien ce que j'aime quoi du doré un peu
de couleurs pastel comme mes créations
plaisait je me suis dit bon bah j'ai
créé mon propre emploi et puis j'ai
essayé de monter ma boîte et puis de
vendre mes créations elle a un talent là
deux noms qu'elle avait sûrement pas
exploiter ou pas tenté avant ça et puis
ça a été la mort ce de départ enchaîné
par par la subvention du tage non elle a
pu bénéficier
et puis on sent vraiment véritablement
qu'elle était pas nous y là dedans
[Musique]
là
qu'est ce que tu vois
moi que je suis là que je suis
disponible
ça change pour maintenant son papa
qu'ils partent tous les matins et
balayez contente que je sois là avec
elle et puis qu'on puisse travailler
toutes les deux être ça pas été simple
parce que déjà il faut trouver moyens
financiers de créer son entreprise qui
n'est pas toujours évident et puis à la
chambre des métiers
madame bâ bo m'a orientée on m'a dit
qu'il y avait une nouvelle aide qui
allait être mise en place a zappé le
tage c'était pour les gens qui avaient
jusqu'à 30 ans et j'avais tout juste 30
ans j'allais avoir 31 je me suis dit
c'est le bon moment
je fonce
du coup ça a pris après six mois pour
monter un dossier un business plan et
cetera à ses six mois bénéfique que ça
m'a permis vraiment de préparer mon
projet de voir comment ça allait se
passer par rapport à la comptabilité
voir avec elle chiffre à peu près il
faut que je fasse vraiment me préparer
quoi ça m'a permis déjà d'investir dans
une bonne machine à coudre dans du bon
matériel
et puis de gérer tout ce qui est
d'entités visuel faire mon logo et
cetera ah oui ça vaut vraiment la peine
et puis c'est c'est une subvention
donc si on a un beau projet qu'on y
croie main pourquoi pas essayer on a
déjà les aides du tage du département
faut il faut essayer avec le modèle
communique ses coiffures les marchés
c'est plutôt lui vendre en ligne et puis
oui de temps en temps faire les marchés
et puis les salons
[Musique]
mavenir bas j'espère que finaliste ya ça
va ça va marcher
j'espère que dans ma marque sera connu
la réunion et puis que je pourrais faire
plein d'enfants heureux avec mes
créations pastel et la petite touche de
peps que j'aime retrouver ça j'ai des
gens s'ils des enfants et des bébés
voilà et puis faire plaisir aussi aux
mamans plus tard j'aimerais faire des
tutos couture partager aussi ma passion
avec avec d'autres mamans aussi voilà
[Musique]